The Joe Rogan Experience so tell me
about the Queen Mary that's the
beginning for you guys that's the number
one origin you went there to do what
so what was really interesting is we did
a lot of the abandoned stuff but every
once in a while we would do like a
haunted thing because those creepy
stories and you know the lore of
everything is really interesting whether
or not you believe in it or not at that
time we didn't really believe in any of
the ghost stuff we're like all right but
this is gonna be a great video because
everyone loves telling the stories
um but we just got I don't know what it
was but someone forwarded us something
saying that for the first time in 30
years the Queen Mary in Long Beach which
is like one of those haunted ships like
New York Times uh like top 10 most
haunted places in the world we filmed
Fear Factor there once really yeah
that's great it's a beautiful ship they
do a comedy show there sometimes no way
didn't know yeah for a while they had a
regular uh comedy night there on the
Queen Mary yeah I didn't realize how
like famous it was but they have that
they have like haunted houses they have
a ton of different attractions there but
there's this one room
b340 uh that hadn't been open for 30
years and allegedly they closed it down
because uh there's multiple unexplained
murders and or suicides in that room and
we're like whoa like you know if this is
the first week this is open after 30
years this is going to be an amazing
story to tell or you know video film and
so we went in there trying to make
something or like trying to get
something we obviously didn't really
believe that much so we were like all
right let's just see if it happens if
there's going to be a haunted location
it'll be this uh we toured around did
the whole thing uh weren't getting much
and we're kind of frustrated at that
point because we're like all right this
is supposed to be the cream of the crop
this is supposed to be the big big wig
like why can't we get something to
happen uh and so it was four o'clock in
the morning at this time we've been
trying for hours of just sitting in
circles like asking out and we didn't
have any equipment at this time this is
like the first place we ever went to so
we were just like Meandering like the
hallways being like is anything here
yeah
on camera and nothing was happening and
so we're like fine I guess
let's do this let's just like leave like
it's fun to tell the story let's just
leave uh and so we turn off the camera
and start packing up we walk start
walking towards the door and as soon as
we turn like actually we're about to
like get out of the room the faucet
turns on like full blast for four
seconds and then turns back off and we
all like actually like you know freeze
and freak out two of our roommates that
were there at the time like just
immediately started like crying we were
like we ran in we're like okay how is
that actually possible at all maybe
that's a sign of like it doesn't want to
be filmed and it doesn't want us to
leave so maybe let's just not not film
this and try one more time just for the
just for the heck of it and so that's
what we did but this time it worked and
to like the weirdest extent we just like
put away all of our cameras we sat in
the most serious tone saying like Okay
guys like before this didn't really
believe so like if this is happening
let's let's have something happen and so
we all sit in the dark together and we
start calling out questions and we're
like okay
like is there anybody here we hear a
knock
and so we're like okay maybe that's
something very faint though it was like
a tap like a tap and so like okay let's
just run with that can you tap more than
once and there's like three tabs all
right okay this is really weird like can
we start asking questions and how loud
are you saying this like is it possible
that someone could have heard you from
another room that's what we thought so
going like we were talking probably like
this but then there was times where we
talked like really quiet and like we we
tested everything but so what we did is
we decided let's ask questions using
these tabs so we we said tap once for
yes tap anything more than once for no
we had a yes or no conversation for 35
minutes with something that we cannot
explain and we did everything because we
were skeptical with this did you film
any of this we didn't think so
but apparently one of our friends he's
like super religious was like hey no
matter what the entire night he was
keeping an audio recording we had no
idea we had no idea he was doing that so
nobody talked about it so if there was
something there no it didn't know either
yeah we had no idea he had pulled that
out like we genuinely were like okay no
one's film we even say in this audio
recording like no one's filming there's
no [ __ ] like everyone please like be
serious about this and so we had this
conversation back and forth and we try
to trick it you know like we would ask
questions in different manners like okay
is there more than one of you yes and
then we'd say are you alone and it would
say no back and forth trying to get this
thing and the story kept straight the
entire time and we were like okay come
on there could be someone like screwing
with us this is like on you know the
news of being like haunted place like
what's going on what was crazy about it
too is all the knocks they weren't just
coming from one one section that would
make sense if like maybe something
outside was like tapping
um these knocks would be like below us
and then above us to our sides some
would be louder than other ones we went
out to the hallway a couple times and we
realized that we were like the last room
besides like this like utility room to
our left
um and obviously we had like basically
that whole like floor to ourselves
um as well since it was super late
um yeah and then like sometime in the
middle we were like what okay like let's
like ask a question under a breath yeah
like okay
like this this thing does not want us to
leave and at that moment the entire
floor shook boom like we were like oh my
God what was that you can feel the
vibration in your feet crashing on the
ship or something was huge and so we're
like Okay so this thing doesn't want us
to leave and maybe we should just like
ask questions under our breath for the
rest of the time just so we know it's
not some employee it's not someone like
screwing with us the entire time so fast
fast uh fast forward to the very end we
were like okay we've had a bunch of
conversations at this point we really
believe if this is truly something I
want to know something about something
deeper than just yes or no questions or
or just like something silly of like how
many people are here so I decided
let's ask about religion
and I ask out
is there a heaven and it knocks three
times meaning no and at that point our
two religious friends that were there
like immediately jumped up and said we
have to leave right now we had no idea
why what's going on like I'll tell you
in the car like do like just don't look
back let's go let's leave and so we
walked out we left we got all the way to
the car without anyone saying anything
and as soon as we got in the car wreck
what's going on like why do we have to
leave he's like well in the Christian
religion
the anything like demonic or evil is
supposed to
like basically disprove that there is a
heaven in order you know and so what
they're saying is like we don't think
this is some like Spirit or some
something paranormal there we think it
was something that was
trying to lead you away from heaven or
demonic territory type thing but that
also just depends on what you believe in
obviously like our roommates were very
very Christian very religious and so
when they heard the knocks saying no uh
they thought it was just kind of like a
sign from like a demon to like steers
away from from God saying like this does
not exist and so
um they without question ran before we
could even we kind of were wanting to
stay there to
ask more things it was really
interesting because this is your first
experience first anything paranormal
well first very believable one there has
been plenty of times where we hear
things or like you know things are scary
in like the abandoned places but they're
also decrepit old places they're freak
and stuff yeah old Dark Places make you
freak out exactly this is the first
conversation we should say that we've
had so
up into that point did you believe in
ghost before and like what is it what is
the feeling like when you have to sort
of process the end of that day so that
was a Monumental change not only like
our career but also like our at least my
like thought process in life because yes
I had the idea that maybe something's
else something else is out there like a
grown up a Christian
um but at that time we had gone to so
many scary places we'd you know tackled
a bunch of like life questions
philosophical questions uh throughout
our time together and we're like
okay like after asking about it like for
me I was like losing like faith in
something else I was like okay maybe
maybe we're just the only things out
here and after that moment
I had like a full-on like breakdown the
next day like I like I was like
everything that I thought was not real
now becomes real and I had like pretty
much lost any any sort of like Faith at
that point but there was even a video of
me online like sitting on my bedroom
floor like crying to camera saying like
I truly didn't believe and now this
instance opens up this whole world like
maybe I don't immediately believe a
hundred percent
but the question of if there is
something else out there is now back in
my brain and I want to chase that and so
after the whole arrest and going to the
Hana stuff that was like it wasn't
necessarily we were like a thousand
percent Believers the second we like had
this experience but it was so intriguing
because it was one of those things that
we couldn't explain we told this story
so many times and the audio of this
actually happening the Knox is online so
many people don't believe it because
they weren't there and we wouldn't
believe it if we weren't there and so we
we understand that people don't believe
us when we talk about these things
however
just the idea that it could be real and
the idea that could happen again is
what's so intriguing and is why we got
into it and we're like okay if we can
just keep doing this and keep getting
more and more proof like that feeling of
Hope of like okay there is something
else out there and it is not just okay
we're just gonna live and die here on
the planet it's so special no matter
what you believe in no matter what
religion you have it's like we realize
that that experience for us it taught us
that there is something else it's more
spiritual than anything
um and we wanted to spread that message
as well to as many people as possible
again no matter what they believed in
but your roommates thought it was
demonic they were they took like the
Christian route and that's again that's
up to whoever is viewing this or
experiencing it themselves but yeah they
they took it very well how did you feel
did you feel like it was a demon or did
you feel like it was a ghost or dead
people would you think it was
I don't know at the time I definitely
thought it was like a demon because
these two guys are like yelling at me
like dude this is 100 without a shout of
a doubt like a demon and I'm like well I
don't know exactly what I believe in
like this is already like rattling my
brain right now
um but it was scary and what was what
was scarier
um is trying to go back into it and
repeating the process because like we
didn't know what we're messing with if
it was a demon like hell maybe if it is
all real are we
just screwing ourselves over by like
going and are you inviting that thing
into your life how many times did you
guys go to the Queen Mary
three four times yeah three or four
times so you went back after that we did
did you leave the uh roommates at home
at that point yeah like our final stent
which was actually last year we hadn't
gone back in three years but we wanted
to like the the Queen Mary actually shut
down which was sad oh really what was
that last year uh they lost like funding
and whatever they might be opening up
now they're trying to like raise money
and like get it back up but yeah so we
thought this was the last time we'd ever
see the ship so we're like let's go say
goodbye to the thing that literally
started this whole adventure for us and
so Kobe and I went back alone same room
b340 same room alone did they rent that
room out to anybody they do now they do
now but for the 30 years they didn't for
the 30 years we were like the first
people to get to it that's so crazy but
again that's all alleged as well like
who knows if it's like a marketing Ploy
and again we were so skeptical that like
Sam and I when those knocks first
started to happen like we were like
looking under things we're like this
room has to be bugged see if you can
find anything about that room find
anything about the Queen Mary room 340.
yeah it's a b340 d340. so they told you
that there was multiple murders that
took place in that room yeah I mean you
guys are just like an hour away from
killing your roommates oh my God yeah
like if we kept going at it I kept
asking questions he just turns on us
it just starts talking to you
oh God it gets the chills what does it
say on the wall so you can scripture
well they have um literally experiences
of each like different family yeah
there's a ton oh my God so it's like
openly haunted yeah so anytime someone
has like a crazy experience that they
deem notable they'll ride it on the wall
there's our thumbnail right there it's
the Bloody Mary wall yeah and they have
instructions to do Bloody it's
definitely cheesy a little bit like they
have the Bloody Mary like Bloody Mary
what what does that mean so bloody mary
is like this challenge that a lot of
people used to do like as like children
or whatever you like go in front of a
mirror turn the light off have one
candle it's been around three times
while saying Bloody Mary Bloody Mary
Bloody Mary oh so it's Candyman exactly
yeah yeah so it's the evolution of
Candyman and so that's like gimmicky
obviously but there's a lot of stories
all over the that's the one that turned
on yeah and so this room is there any
documentation that people actually died
in that room yeah I was gonna say I'm
I'm curious because like when we went
there again like we were very different
than where we're at now like we didn't
do like super extensive research what we
did is we like would you know we'd take
the article that it says it is but
obviously we're not going back and fact
checking that and then we go and talk to
the employees and so most of our stories
were all like first-hand encounters with
the employees that were there uh or
things that they would tell us rather
than you know and the employees seem to
believe it every employee like we've met
pretty much at all these haunted places
are True Believers those are the ones
that said like they could see stuff
following us
so yeah people that work there like are
super into like the Paranormal and stuff
that's what's [ __ ] right because
there's only a handful of those people
that are there day in day out right
right like and you can dismiss that
or it's like or it might be real right
that's the thing it's just the thing
that gnaws at me it's like it's so easy
to dismiss ghosts oh ghosts are [ __ ]
but the problem is are so many people
that say they've seen it over so many
years literally hundreds and hundreds of
years it makes you wonder because if
there are multiple dimensions and if
life is if they're you're you you are a
physical body that's carrying around a
soul like where does that thing go yeah
if energy doesn't die where is it all
and what happens if something horrible
takes place like there's some crazy
traumatic moment gunshots and stab
wounds and like where does that Soul go
is that what is it possible that things
get trapped right in between worlds and
that these people that work in these
places or you guys all right experience
exactly